it's the first ever
entirely virtual ces the fact that the
world's largest consumer electronics
show has gone online this year
means that we at wired can't really
experience it
the way we normally would we can't see
the dancing robots or the giant displays
or the smart toilets
in person but we're still trying to
cover it because technology is marching
on
companies are trying their best to adapt
to the pandemic
and they're making big bets on
innovations for the future so i decided
to ask my wired colleagues what they're
seeing
on the ground at ces this year or should
i say through their screens
at ces this year and what's peaking
their interest so i want to take it to
michael colorae
who's my editor mike thanks so much for
joining me on this video
hi lauren mike the big question that i
want to ask you
is does anyone care about ces this year
i do think people care i think you know
consumers care
uh our readers care because you know ces
is the time you get to see
all the stuff that's coming out this
year companies are still showing up and
they're still putting out a bunch of
stuff
so there's gonna be things that you can
buy next christmas season that's usually
what ces is about
also companies show up to do business
with each other you know the tv buyer at
the big box store is going to be talking
to all the tv manufacturers and seeing
what's new
so i think that people still do care
even though it's
smaller and a little bit sadder do you
get the sense
so far from what you're seeing or
hearing from the press conferences
that companies are adequately addressing
some of these crises that we're facing
right now or is it a lot of lip service
and people just want to get to the
robot that pours you a glass of wine i
think some companies are addressing the
pandemic but they're doing it in a
really weird way
like they're showing you all of the
different uv light sanitization
stuff that they've put into their
gadgets and that's not always
effective at killing germs but i think
the fact that everybody is hyper aware
of germs this year
makes those sorts of things a little bit
more appealing so people are
you know catering to that right and
we're also seeing a lot of companies
market their products as ideal work from
home products now because many of us are
spending much more time at home
and working from home and homeschooling
from home have you seen anything in
those categories that you find
particularly interesting
i think the most interesting thing for
working from home is
noise canceling headphones anybody who
lives
with other human beings be they fully
grown
or very small will know the value of a
good pair of noise-cancelling headphones
and like this is a great year for noise
cancelling headphones there are
dozens of them they're all coming down
in price and they all have incredible
battery life so they last
all day so you can shut the world out
all day while you toil at your desk in
your
kitchen or whatever like it seemed for a
while that if you wanted really good
powerful headphones you had to get
big ones that went like around your ears
and now everyone's into buds
i've actually been surprised by the
quality of
wire free earbuds you know the the kinds
that don't have any wires connecting
them just sort of like
apple's airpods everybody makes a
version of those now over the last
couple of years they've been getting
really good
2021 is gonna be the year where you can
buy a pair of those and they're gonna
sound
excellent and they're gonna have really
good battery life what are you hearing
about
immersive audio technology or speakers
that are going to
fill your home with really great sound
yeah one big trend that we see
in audio this year is spatial audio or
3d audio this is a technology that lets
you
take just one speaker like a sound bar
underneath your television
and then it can make it seem like sounds
are coming from all around you so it's
like having surround sound system with
just one speaker
it's really hard to find out if they're
effective but thankfully within the next
five or six months people will start
sending them to us so we can test them
and listen to them mike one of the
things that you and i have both covered
in recent years at ces
is the rise of the franken gadget tell
us about this trend and are we gonna see
more of it this is like the
coffee maker that's also an alarm clock
and a speaker
that weird category of like hybrid
device
this year there's a really cool one that
is like a bluetooth speaker
that is built into a shower head and as
the water flows through the shower head
there's hydroelectric power that powers
the speaker
that's pretty cool i mean i want one
don't you maybe
question mark it's probably my response
for a lot of gadgets at ces
so let's go to julian chicatu who's in
new york and he's been paying a lot of
attention to what's going on
in displays so samsung has its big
fancy micro led tv this is this new
competitor
against ola and oled obviously has this
organic
led so it's basically going to give you
much nicer blacks because every single
pixel is controllable so
when you're seeing black on the tv it's
actually perfectly
pitch black it's turned off this new
competitor is
samsung's micro led tech which is using
millions of leds behind every single
pixel to
further give you excellent blacks and
contrast and better colors
it's positioned to be potentially better
than oled we don't know yet but
it was just spectacular to behold and
that's the sort of way that i think
samsung is going to try and pivot to
you can actually buy this one at this
110 inch version
in korea for about 150 000
so at the moment a little out of reach
maybe one day
so one of the things we saw this week
was tcl which is traditionally known as
a tv maker and one of the things the
company shut off was a
rollable phone what is a rollable phone
and how is it different from a foldable
phone
think a normal phone and then you can
essentially pull out the display whether
it's horizontally or vertically to
enable more screen space so when you
want that extra screen space maybe
you're going to watch a movie or
watch tv show or just use two apps side
by side you can just pull out the
display
the benefit here over foldables is that
foldables are pretty thick and chunky
with a rollable you're basically using a
similar
normal phone that you can just extend
that display out it sounds like we are
going to see some rollable phones
actually come out this year at some
point what are you hearing about
chips and laptops so far there's i think
this
sense that we're all going to eventually
shift a lot of these laptop processes to
arm-based processors which is what apple
is using and arm-based processors are
what we traditionally use in our
smartphone chips for the ability to use
the same type of architecture in your
laptop and your phone
that ideally would mean that you know
transitioning from your laptop to your
phone would be very
very seamless and i mean that if i
pulled up a couple of applications in my
laptop
and then i switched back to my iphone
i'll be able to sort of pull
up those exact same applications in the
same way that i left them from the
laptop
it's still early days even for apple so
we still have to see a lot of the
benefits outside of
improved performance and efficiency so
longer battery life but i think the
sense is that we're gonna see
laptop manufacturers you know sort of
investing
in arm chips for their laptops rather
than going intel
right i keep hearing about how all this
experimentation and chips for laptops is
going to lead us to acpcs
which sounds like a band but actually
just means always connected personal
computers
but i have to say i like the idea of an
ac pc
i think it's just a natural thing that
developers gonna really like because
it makes you stay in their app more
often i think if you can just
quickly seamlessly transition over from
one device to the next
let's go to alan henry in new york who's
been covering everything that's going on
in games
hey alan i like your blazer i got to
dress up for something
that's right tell me what you're seeing
so far in the gaming world at ces
some of the big things obviously off the
tail end of last year we got new
consoles
pc hardware we have new graphics cards
we have a ton of new games right so
leading into the beginning of this year
we're seeing a lot
of people kind of capitalizing on all of
that new hardware so there's a lot of
software
features around cloud streaming and game
streaming and streaming not just
games across different devices but also
like on twitch and things like that so
there's some community advancements
going on but not a lot of
big hardware releases at the moment
because
you know they already announced a whole
bunch of things and one thing i'm
hearing is that we're going to see more
amd chips and laptops and i'm wondering
if you could tell us what this means for
pc gamers
amd has been manufacturing some really
really affordable
uh cpus which means pc gamers are
getting a lot of more bang for their
buck when it comes to building their own
gaming pcs and companies that make their
own
gaming pcs as well are able to pack more
power into the same price point that's
one thing
yeah amd's been firing on all cylinders
and that includes consoles too
sony and microsoft have been including
amd processors in
the playstation 5 and the xbox series x
which
has done a huge thing for narrowing that
kind of pc console gap so this is
getting really in the weeds but another
thing that i'm hearing about at ces so
far this week
hdmi ports on tvs are getting an upgrade
the point where they can now
support the higher refresh rates they're
getting more high power so they can
support the new gaming consoles talk
about this
with an upgrade to hdmi you're getting
frame rates on
large screens that traditionally were
reserved for
smaller pc displays with really powerful
graphics cards
the difference between 30 and 60 frames
per second in a console game used to be
like the big marker of whether or not
your console was any good
and now we're starting to see console
developers start talking about
developing their games
in 120 hertz or like they do for pc
games like 144 or something like that
they're starting to go up exponentially
to the point where
uh it's not so much about powering as
many pixels
as it is creating a very emotive
seamless experience that doesn't stutter
and doesn't load along typically at ces
in las vegas every year
nvidia puts on a pretty big event they
make a splash
they show all kinds of new technologies
but
it doesn't appear like that's going to
be possible this year because of the
virtual nature of ces
what are you hearing from nvidia every
year nvidia
releases their brand new desktop
graphics cards they did that at the end
of last year
now it's their turn to kind of show off
the chipsets based on that
that are low power for laptops and other
mobile devices
i don't see them with any announcements
that are going to
resolve the pipeline problems they've
been having but they will have some cool
laptops cards to show off
and what are some of the pipeline
problems they've been having can you sum
those up quickly
i mean i shouldn't say that that's it's
their problem specifically it's just
that they can't produce enough graphics
cards to meet the demand
we know these products have been hard to
find i want to thank you for your
patience as we continue to work hard to
catch up
i'll just be over here salty that i
can't get my hands on
all right let's go to adrian soh who's
coming to us from portland hey adrian
you're keeping an eye on all the
connected fitness stuff at ces this year
what are you seeing so far so a lot of
the wearables that i normally cover
during ces have opted
not to come this year so fitbit won't be
showing anything
garmin isn't showing anything at ces
this year
other companies from smaller to larger
ones
are debuting similar fitness platforms
two of the ones that i'm interested
in this year are samsung health is
introducing
a personalized ai coaching platform and
bowflex has a platform called journey
that's incorporated with the bowflex
bikes in the same way that the peloton
app
is integrated with the peloton bike we
saw peloton
really blow up this year and a lot of
companies
are hoping to lure even more people in
hopefully at a lower price point
what kind of trends have you seen at ces
so far this year that are reflective of
this trend of all of us being home the
one that i was really
excited about that i definitely don't
have room for in our closet
was the kohler stillness tub which is a
meditation tub
and for a mom of two kids i'm thinking
of it as
the escape tub like things like a smart
faucet that
may have been of limited utility when
most of us
had kids that went to school and i never
realized how annoying it was to have
to turn the faucet on and off for him
every like
30 seconds to wash his hands or rinse
something off and now i'm like yeah
definitely getting a smart faucet that
might give me back half an hour
at least of my life what a time to be
alive
there's anything we've learned about ces
over the years it's that there are a lot
of great ideas and concepts presented
but they don't necessarily
ship right away or help you out in the
immediate future
that's one of the main things about ces
trying to fit itself into the timeline
of covid19 like these are devices that
we're going to be
seeing six months or a year or two years
in advance
and who knows what the world is going to
look like then
all right so let's go to my colleague
boone ashworth who's in san francisco
boone i was really looking forward to
chatting with you because you're really
focused this week
on companies at ces that are involved in
some way in
hygiene tech technologies that are
supposed to help us kill
germs faster tell me what you're seeing
this week
sanitization disinfecting antimicrobial
tech is very much in this year so we're
seeing
uv light in everything from wireless
chargers
to refrigerators to full-on robots
that automatically go around in stores
or offices and disinfect everything
air purifiers anti-microbial materials
and laptops backpacks
phone cases basically you name it it's
got clean tech on it what have you seen
so far that you've said to yourself
i could see there being a use for that i
could see there being a use for
combination wireless charger and uv
sanitizers so you
put your phone on this wireless charging
mat and it also sanitizes it with uv
light
anti-microbial materials thinking about
you know your phone being cleaner than
the disgusting germ magnet that it is
right now
is always great we're also seeing some
folks roll out
touchless technologies right i think
voice and gesture controls are big
and weirdly facial recognition as well
touch screens and say a store mall or
something like that
that you can just wave at or talk to and
not have to touch
would be great boom do you have a sense
of how well these disinfecting
anti-germ technologies actually work so
a lot of it
is based on science that is sound so
things like air filtration and uv light
protect against the virus or limit the
flow
of the virus to the air or on surfaces
the problem is that a lot of it really
depends on
context right so if you have an air
purifier
that you want to clean a room out with
it has to be big enough it has to be
efficient enough
to get the airflow in the room to cycle
through
and get the virus out if you have you
know some of the
small kind of handheld air purifiers
that we've been seeing at ces
your contacts just might be too big
for the tech that you're using is there
anything else that people should know
about these
sanitizing disinfecting technologies i
think just
understanding how they actually work and
how long some of them
take to be effective uvc light for
instance has been shown to
eliminate the coronavirus like a
hospital setting
that uvc light is a lot more intense to
the point where it could harm your skin
or your eyes
a lot of gadgets that we're seeing now
are coming out with something called far
uvc light
and that is a shorter wavelength and
therefore more gentle but at the same
time
that light in order to properly
disinfect something
needs to sit on it for a long time it's
not going to be as simple as just
beaming over your phone or your
restaurant table and then expecting it
to be completely disinfected so
just understanding the limitations of
this technology is important
thanks to all of you for watching this
video and for following along as we
cover
our first ever entirely virtual ces
there are some interesting things coming
out of the show this year no doubt
but it's been a pretty scaled down event
and we hope in the future maybe we can
get back to las vegas and cover it in
person
we have all kinds of stories about ces
on wired.com so go check those out when
you get a chance
and thanks again for watching